i don't really want know what i want to  do for juniors now  how old are you 17 17 yeah so like  you're not supposed to know what you  want to do i want to be a personal  trainer you're so good so how you do are  you doing anything about it i really  like college for two years  you know it's not about better ideas  it's about knowing what makes you happy  so if like you're doing personal  training because it [ __ ] really makes  you happy then you got a chance to do it  it's it's not about is cannabis better  than social media is better than drop  shipping is better than tick tock it's  what the [ __ ] are you about and if  you're about that then you've got a much  better chance to put in the work  to actually make you happy about it  because everyone's chasing money versus  chasing the [ __ ] that makes them happy  or the thing they're good at you know  there's no better there's you being more  self-aware